the smiles at the New York Stock
Exchange couldn't mask what was a
disastrous week for world stock markets
Friday's trading only deepening the
losses the Dow Jones index ended down
13% from record highs with US markets
seeing their biggest weekly sell-off
since the 2008 financial crisis it's
been a similar story for London's main
footsie 100 index in stocks in Europe
while no fewer than seven markets in
Asia have lost more than 10 percent of
their value fueling the plunge the
spread of the coronavirus outside of
China deserted streets in Milan
heightening concerns that kovat 19 is
making an inevitable march across the
globe and raising fears about the
negative effects that efforts to stop
the disease could have on the US economy
fears the White House again tried to
tamp down on Friday everybody whether
you're an investor or whether you're you
know ordinary Main Street person people
should not overreact it's proving to be
a huge test for Larry could Lowe's boss
President Trump who since he took office
has championed record-high stocks as an
endorsement of his presidency but
conversely sees a falling market as
someone else's fault namely the
Democrats competing to unseat him in
this year's election I think the
financial markets are very upset when
they look at the Democrat candidates
standing on that stage making fools out
of themselves and they say if we haven't
have a president like this I think that
has a huge effect yeah but world health
experts including in the u.s. continued
to warn about the dangers of the virus
and critics like his Democratic
presidential challengers have slammed
Trump's downplaying of the threat saying
that he cares more about the market
reaction rather than containing the
virus itself
experts say uncertainties surrounding
the threat is causing jitters it's not
an economic effect exactly yet it's a
virus and it's matter how much blind
faith you want to have in the central
banking structures of the world virus
and epidemiology a little bit outside
their general mandate and no matter how
much you want to ignore pull
risk when countries in industry started
to collapse with an epidemic it's hard
to know how to do that
this week's losses put an end to an
unprecedented period of growth for US
markets whether or not the panicked
sell-off continues will depend not only
on the spread of the coronavirus but
also messages coming out of the White
House Christin salumi al Jazeera New
York